shall we could let's catch you always
need a good four Brewers like me beer is
definitely the spice of life but for my
guests today spice is literally what
makes his world go round and round I've
invited the winking himself Sean Evans
from hot ones here to Barcade one of the
best indie craft beer bars in the world
to school Sean on pairings of spicy
foods with some really great indie craft
beers but then I got a little surprise
for him I'm gonna pull out a beer that's
so spicy
we had to use protective gear to brew
with the peppers that went into it so
this week on that's odd let's drink it
this is the show with spicy beers and
even spicier guests shun it is early in
the morning not too early for a beer
though we're drinking a wee heavy at
9:30 a.m. do you know the style of beer
I'm new to it you know we were talking a
little bit you're like what do you want
to do you want to go sweet you want to
go bitter you want to go roasty and I'm
like you know what 9:30 in the morning
let's go sweet dark will baby step our
ways that's exactly right exactly right
perience today you've literally been to
the pinnacle spice Mountain when you've
gone too far in having something super
spiciest or something things that you've
turned to magic tricks that tamp down
that spice what I've found is that once
you cross that line you're just in that
zone so if I eat a Carolina Reaper I'll
tell Chris I'll be like after I eat this
thing you guys have 15 20 minutes to
shoot with me then I'm in the cab and
I'm in my apartment and I'm just gonna
sort of like ride that wave of pain and
I've found that like there's not much
that's gonna help you get out of that
zone
just time I you know and kind of lined
up this day to help us use our
complementary superpowers from the spice
world old world alright we are gonna do
this to see how beer can influence the
spicy food journey you ready to do this
let's go on the journey my man Cheers
I'm gonna start right in the center of
your wheel hub you dream of wings it's a
little bit blessing it's a little bit
curse and when it comes to this
particular sauce I'm actually pretty
familiar with it this was in the sixth
spot
of season five of hot ones this is karma
sauce out of Pittsford New York so it
has the butternut squash you also have
ghost Muruga
Trinidad scorpion so some really really
spicy peppers are in this sauce this is
actually contrasting pairing we're
having super spicy wings relatively
spicy as you describe this sauce and
we're gonna counterbalance that with a
sweeter beer this is our nama state and
it's like a cozy blanket for your palate
with orange flesh and lemongrass super
approachable let's see how this works
are you a spicy food guy Sam I'm a
medium training wheels spicy food guy I
get the second hottest thingy thing at
Buffalo wallowing so I don't know what
that would be I always say what's your
second hardest [ __ ] I'm gonna go there
it is a pleasant warming it's not brew
all right you know I think that what
ends up happening is that you have such
a heavy spice you know you have
something earthy something so peppery
and then when I chase it down with a
beer that has orange in it you're not
only calling the spice but you're also
hitting the flavor spectrum in a crazy
way yep I think they work well the other
no yeah they dance nicely
[Music]
heading in the second base we're doing a
lamb vindaloo which is one of the
spiciest things you can get off the menu
traditionally this would be paired with
a crisp Pilsner something like a
Kingfisher but we're not going there
that's how the Brits would do it that's
how they were all but we roll using a
British style of beer stout that's made
by our pals in Colorado at left hand so
nitro milk stout lamb vindaloo why are
we deviating from the convention Oh
shine is that a rhetorical question
this is weird this is spicy but I don't
know if it's as spicy as the wig is it I
think that the wings were spicier yeah
but the Lambs delicious mmm what do you
think of the beer what do you think the
pair talk me through this because you
have an Indian spice dish yep we have a
very roasty yep beer yep
what's the connection the more you toast
barley the more there's unfermented
sugars in it so it's gonna be roasty
it's it's super cooked which is what
gives its color so it's gonna be roasty
but it's also gonna have some nice
unfermented sugars to give it some body
that really works to tamp down the spice
in the vindaloo well you know what the
vindaloo might not have been as spicy as
the win but the beer just as delicious
next up we are doing classic street food
a beautiful spicy chicken taco paired
with local cane IPA it's a New England
style IPA which means it's supposed to
be this cloudy we think off rep this is
the kind that I like this is a summery
IPA this might as well have crisp
written on the glass and with these New
England style IPAs the intention is to
add hops late in the process so it's
more about mouthfeel of hops and aroma
of hops but not a crushing bitterness
with brewing the earlier you add hops in
the process the more it contributes to
bitterness the later you add in the
process the more it contributes to aroma
because this is hoppy but it has a sweet
beer taste
so that would be why because they're
putting it late in the game yep and that
sweetness I believe is gonna work well
as a blanket for this place let's find
out
first things first delicious 10 a.m.
taco as a little beer of the day at 10
a.m. I love hanging out with you and
then we'll chase it down people are
always trying to help me out they're
always trying to give me tips exactly
exactly and the beer guys always say IPA
IPA IPA
alcohol is kind of the enemy of spicy
food it blows it up so this pairing
works with this IPA because it's a
relatively low alcohol IPA and it has a
nice amount of unburnable sugar some
sweetness but a higher ABV you might be
just suffering you know from the bite of
the spicy taco that you ate and then the
beer that you chase it down with isn't
helping no it's just when you're turning
the volume up yeah it's turn alcohol
definitely amplifies this place
we got a nice base in our stomach now
right yes I'm so full right mm-hmm so I
say we belly up to the bar
you're the spice Lord I'm coming at you
like a spider monkey
now with a beer that's gonna be in your
mace whoa yeah yeah hi follow me let's
go Sam pepper spring in your mouth
doesn't sound pleasant in theory but
what if you could turn that Scoville
glass into a delicious roast east up in
your base that's our beer and it uses
the active ingredient of mace brand
pepper spray oleoresin capsicum say that
five times fast to infuse the brew with
liquid heat alongside the food grade
chili oil
we added mace the spice cinnamon vert
and chips milk sugars and coffee for
nuanced flavor it's spicy but complex
just like my guests Sean Evans who made
his name deconstructing celebrities
while eating increasingly spicy chicken
wings on this is a beautiful dark inky
stout made with the weapons-grade
capsicum from mace and things are going
so well Sam give it a second gonna ride
with it you just got on this bus I've
been through the spicy food gauntlet
many many times and this is a familiar
thing where you can almost tell how it's
gonna chase you the moment it hits you
so I'll know a creeper before the
creeper creeps so this is going to hit
you if you don't know what you're
looking for I think it's great I've been
here before the early judging you're not
a joke a comfortable jog you ready to do
some parkour let's do it you ready bunts
up some buildings yeah let's move this
[ __ ] aside I'm gonna pull out some
wicked weapons like this one whoa whoa
this thing's called Randall dogfish had
invented this machine it basically acts
as a catalyst to pull the natural oils
off of anything you put in it and guess
who I contacted for this Oh your pal
smokin Edie wow I don't even know what
he sent me I'm pulling these out of my
intestines as I speak I smell a Carolina
Reaper you're looking at over two
million Scoville that's what that's
you're responsible I know that we have
chocolate boot lahir 1.4 million
Scoville and then we have something else
right that I can't quite put my finger
on but that's very smoking I had to send
a mystery bag of like whatever so let's
start adding these peppers if not the
spiciest beer ever made definitely top
five all right let's do this
[Music]
I want you to tell me what you think of
this
cheers Cheers let's go on this journey
buckle up
[Music]
stay with it stay with it stay with it
don't let know that you're afraid I'm
not it's a hard front okay you can't get
on top of me smoking it what are you
gonna learn here's what I would say yeah
this is by far the spiciest beer I've
ever had in my life I didn't know as
many pours on my face but it's just
something about the way that beer
Masha's up with peppers that like I
could finish this class you know and I
think that maybe you could - it's very
hot but as we've learned today and maybe
it's coming full circle now yeah with
the right beer you can get on top of it
with the right beer you can compliment
that and with the right beer it's like
the perfect 50/50 mix of pain and
pleasure Sean we did it we pushed the
spicing envelope thank you for being my
guinea pig thank you for being part of
this Congrats sir there's my pleasure my
friend here soon
[Applause]
[Music]
you